une vraie problématique par rapport au
pouvoir d'achat des gens je pense que
aujourd'hui quand tu es une famille de
quatre ou cinq tu as envie de manger
entre 15 et 30 euros on va dire pour se
faire plaisir donc c'est sûr que les
buffets à volonté c'est la tentation
facile on s'est croisé tout à l'heure je
suis très content qu'il soit là parce
que ça pour le coup c'est un restaurant
qui est validé mais on n'est pas on
n'est pas à 15 ou 20 € comme il t'a dit
parce que la viande il faut que ce soit
un certain prix on voit dans le
reportage les grands buffets de Narbonne
on est plutôt aux alentours de 53,50 €
si je dis pas de bêtises mais c'est
pareil c'est parce qu'il y a de la
qualité sur de la pizza et des pâtes
c'est faisable d'avoir une offre qui est
valable pour un prix qui reste très
accessible c'est beaucoup plus difficile
quand tu veux avoir une autre
gastronomie donc c'est sûr que quand tu
as dans des buffets chinois ou ce genre
de choses et je stigmatise pas du coup
la communauté chinoise parce que nous on
recommande sur France Bleu très
régulièrement plein de super resto
chinois et on en a plein à Paris en
Île-de-France mais c'est vrai que dans
ces endroits là en général bah pour 15
euros 90 le midi et 19,90 le soir on
mange pas bien voilà alors il y a les
gros mangeurs dans les buffets à volonté
coûte cher et puis il y a des petits
mangeurs qui rapportent beaucoup au
restaurant ils ont suivi une dame qui
mange plutôt équilibrée et regardez
combien elle rapporte au resto regardez
ça
c'est plutôt ce que prend cette dame la
première assiette était crudité
diversifié varié et maintenant je prends
des petites croquettes avec des petites
pommes de terre voilà et pour son repas
on a fait les calculs elle ne coûte
vraiment pas cher au restaurant en
entrée l'assiette de crudités ne dépasse
pas les 70 centimes pour le plat
principal des féculents et une autre
côte c'est environ 2,40 et pour le
dessert une coupe de fruits et 4
mignardises on arrive à 2,24 soit un
couple à taux pour François de 5,84 €
c'est où alors c'est vrai que
l'équilibre il est plutôt
l'équilibre ici tue pas uniquement sur
ce que vont manger certains moi c'est
sûr je mangeais 8 places je suis un gros
mangeur après je vais à la salle comme
un dingue mais le truc c'est vraiment
que ils vont gagner c'est surtout sur le
personnel ça c'est la première chose
parce que tu as pas des gens qui sont en
train de servir des assiettes ils sont
plutôt monotaches la préparation
également on va y avoir du gain de temps
en cuisine donc déjà ils économisent sur
ça et puis après il y a des économies
d'échelle par rapport aux commandes qui
vont être faites c'est le cas également
des bouillons c'est à dire que plus tu
vas commander et moins tu vas payer ta
marchandise cher et l'autre chose sur
laquelle ils vont gagner aussi c'est
qu'en général ce sont des grands
restaurants donc on fait beaucoup de
couverts et là encore on a des économies
d'échelle qui sont très intéressantes
alors avec la nourriture à volonté le
restaurateur à son petit secret pour
gagner de l'argent chaque jour il mise
sur les boissons vous allez me dire si
c'est vrai ou pas quand même
le chiffre d'affaires ne se fait pas
seulement sur la vente des formules du
ferventer notre chiffre d'affaires qui
se fait sur la vente des boissons tout
ce qui est cocktail donc soyez prêt dès
maintenant n'a pas oublié les consignes
d'Ornella dites-moi vous désirez une
boisson elles ne sont jamais comprise
dans le menu et c'est sur ce poste qu'il
marche le plus sur les sodas c'est x 3 à
acheter environ un euro 20 ils sont
vendus ici 3,80 € au final l'addition
est bien souvent supérieure au prix
affiché du menu 30 euros par personne
c'est la moyenne chez François
aujourd'hui encore son seuil de
rentabilité de 5000 euros sera largement
dépassé il a fait deux fois plus de
chiffre d'affaires
alors c'est ça sur les boissons sur les
boissons on fait du volume donc
250 couverts jours à peu près 250
boissons
puisque la première chose qui a demandé
c'est ce qu'il y a dû voir donc voilà
donc c'est sûr que la vente
additionnelle
la vente additionnelle c'est hyper
important pour un restaurant mais de
toute façon c'est le cas sur la plupart
des restos aujourd'hui on trouve des
restaurants étoilés à Paris où on peut
aller manger entre 35 et 40 euros le
midi pour du entrée plat dessert bien
évidemment ils vont marcher sur le vin
ils vous font la cuisine à perte parce
que tu as du gars qui sont en cuisine tu
en as cinq qui sont au service tu as un
sommelier donc la vente additionnelle
est très importante la différence c'est
qu'au lieu d'avoir une carafe d'eau
fraîche bien souvent ils ont une carafe
d'eau qui vont pas renouveler très
souvent qui va être un peu tiède donc
qui pousse un peu à la consommation mais
c'est sur ça qu'il faut également leur
beurre alors il y a aussi des desserts
pour gagner du temps et de l'argent le
resto un resto de steak à volonté à ces
petits secrets pour les desserts aussi
regardez on sert jusqu'à 600 couverts
par jour à ce tarif il y a une exception
fait maison si les poissons et crustacés
sont du jour pour les fritures et les
desserts c'est une autre histoire et
François l'assume totalement il serait
possible de faire maison ça c'est
impossible
grâce aux surgelés il gagne un temps
précieux mais aussi de l'argent vous les
achetez combien au niveau des
milliardises on a à peu près à 20 30
centimes caisses faut pas qu'on dépasse
à peu près 50 centimes
au restaurant il nous demande souvent il
nous chauffe pour qu'on a s'arrête pas
au restaurant on va se dire les choses
clairement c'est pareil pour les
boulangeries et pâtisseries moi j'étais
au salon de la restauration rapide cette
semaine d'accord c'était du côté de la
Porte de Versailles aujourd'hui tu peux
monter une boulangerie pâtisserie sans
avoir de personnel puisque aujourd'hui
tout est faisable
il y a des grosses sociétés qui font de
l'artisanat qui est assez qualitative
sur faut peut-être pour un chou qui a du
craquelin ou sur certains desserts ou
c'est un peu plus compliqué mais tu peux
avoir de la qualité tu as également
métro qui fait une qualité qui est
moindre moi j'ai vu à ce salon quelqu'un
qui fait des glaces il m'a dit sur
avanie j'ai 12 références il a une glace
à la vanille qui est presque à 50 euros
le litre qui est quand même peu
foisonner c'est à dire il y a pas trop
d'air dedans il y a vraiment beaucoup de
vanille on est à 50 euros le litre mais
il va avoir aussi de la glace pour un
kebab ou un restaurant de street food
qui va pas vouloir mettre une bonne
glace qui va pas être très cher donc
aujourd'hui tu peux acheter tout déjà
fait et c'est sur ça aussi qu'il y a une
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent oui nous on
les fait nous en fait
moi je te fais confiance
pas non mais regarde pas il t'a validé
en plus dans le capital du fait d'hier
soir s'ils ont également évoqué le
concept des pizzas à volonté alors on
sait que les restaurateurs marchent
plutôt bien sur les pizzas mais comment
font-ils pour gagner de l'argent
lorsqu'elles sont dispo à volonté
regardez
du buffet la Bianca la recette la plus
gourmande avec une pâte très épaisse et
ce n'est pas un hasard mais vous avez
mis la plus bourrative en premier
exactement ça c'est l'idée de papa les
idées s'affusent dans sa tête toujours
ici la pâte fait 300 g contre 200 g
habituellement
voilà donc c'est la pâte c'est ça donc
c'est le le
secret c'est pas que la pâte sur ça bon
après je veux pas critiquer les
journalistes d'am6 mais en fait à
plusieurs recettes de pizza les pizzas
romaines elles vont être de toute façon
un peu comme frites un peu comme les
pizzas qu'on peut avoir chez Pizza Hut
avec une pâte une pâte qui va être plus
épaisse ensuite on a de la Napolitaine
et autant de recettes de pizza que nous
on va faire de pain en France là où il
gagne de l'argent c'est sûr ce qu'ils
vont mettre dedans c'est à dire le type
de farine déjà d'une part le type
d'huile également qui va rentrer dans la
composition de la pâte mais également
les ingrédients qui vont mettre dessus
et ce qui vont mettre du fromage qui est
un fromage avec également dedans des
ingrédients qui sont des ingrédients
végétaux ou est-ce qu'on va être
vraiment sur de la mozzarella de Bull
Flon ou autre chose le jambon qu'on va
mettre dessus est-ce que c'est un jambon
qui est nitrité qui est bourré de
saloperies dedans ou est-ce que c'est du
vrai bon jambon comme le prince de Paris
parce qu'on a plus qu'un seul jambon de
Paris ils ont même pas le droit à la de
l'appeler jambon de Paris puisque la
marque est déposée ailleurs c'est quand
même dingue donc voilà il y a les
ingrédients qui comptent mais sur la
pizza je dirais que
ça me choque moins la formule à volonté
puisqu'on sait vu le prix de revient
d'une pizza pour le restaurateur que
même si on en mange deux il gagne encore
de l'argent ça me gêne moins que sur
d'autres types de restauration est-ce
que vous voulez j'ai une question
[Rires]
j'aime bien aller au japonais à volonté
non mais je veux savoir s'il y avait des
clients déjà qui étaient venus qui
mangeaient tellement qui abusé que
c'était pas du tout rentable et vous
êtes obligé de leur dire STOP non
j'aimerais la viande
comme ça
faut arrêter d'aller dans les
restaurants japonais à volonté tu peux
pas avoir du bon sushi dans un
restaurant
mais bon voilà c'est très rare
tu es vraiment
[Rires]
salés vous arrêter
toute façon c'est pas moi qui décide
c'est la direction en tout cas vous
devez servir on peut même pas prendre un
dessert là
intéressante parce que si on rebondit
sur ce sujet là ils expliquaient aussi
maintenant comment ils font pour
justement diminuer le gâchis donc ils
expliquaient qu'il y avait l'assiette
qui était encore remplie qui est qui
coûtait 10 euros si on gâchait trop et
il y a aussi une application qui fait
que les personnes peuvent acheter un
espèce de package ou de ce qui reste
dans le restaurant ils ont pas le choix
de ce qu'on leur met dans la barquette
mais il paye je crois que c'était 5
euros quelque chose comme ça donc
c'était vachement intéressant de savoir
comment il recyclait les aliments
c'est pareil c'est un faux sujet on met
une amende aux gens qui finissent par
leurs assiettes mais excuse-moi si tu
prends quelque chose qui est pas bon
historique à Paris qui propose de la
restauration traditionnelle de qualité
après abordable et servir rapidement ça
cartonne ça depuis le 19e siècle Daniel
tu vois déjà non mais c'est vrai tu vois
regardez
c'est miroirs dans le style Belle Époque
et c'est lustre imposants le petit
pharaon est un bouillon un type de
restaurant qui date du 19e siècle avec
décor luxueux et tout petit prix la
carte des prix très compétitifs des
entrées à partir de 1 euro 90 et des
plats à 7,50 €. grâce à cette promesse
tous les médias à l'entrée c'est le même
spectacle les gens se pressent avant
même l'ouverture et ouais c'est un
carton le bouillon pharaon c'est
entièrement validé la décoration elle
est superbe on est vraiment dans un lieu
qui est historique on est en plein cœur
des Halles là où les bouillons ont pris
leur essence c'est vrai qu'on mange pour
pas très cher moi je vais dire j'ai été
il y a pas si longtemps que ça fêter mon
anniversaire là-bas j'avais un peu des
potes invités mes parents etc je me suis
dit ouais d'accord pour payer donc j'ai
voulu un truc pas trop cher tu vois le
problème c'est que tu peux pas réserver
donc forcément tu te tapes la file
d'attente mais une fois que tu es dedans
tu manges bien après mon père lui ce
qu'il dit c'est je vois pas l'intérêt
d'aller au restaurant pour manger ce que
ma mère
c'est hyper traduit mais c'est bien les
pensions sont plutôt généreuses que ce
soit pharaon il y a également le
bouillon République il y a Chartier où
il y a à chaque fois une file d'attente
de dingue du côté des Grands Boulevards
même à Versailles juste à côté du
château maintenant il y a un nouveau
bouillon qui a ouvert il y a quelques
mois le petit bouillon Versailles qui
est très très bien et ça cartonne ce
genre de concept parce que les gens ils
savent que finalement pour une vingtaine
d'euros tu manges entre plat dessert et
tu vas te régaler
j'ai stoppé le bouillon non mais c'est
vrai donc il y a des steak frites
alors ils ont un secret bien particulier
pour le moment ça mord pas donc
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je peux te dire tu vas te faire
circoncire à une deuxième fois
mais bon à très bien merci
incroyable David il faut que tu
reviennes un peu tu as ta place ici je
l'adore David
et pas Bernard j'aime beaucoup Bernard
mais
Daniel Bernard peut chauffer aussi on a
fait un chifoumi au départ pour savoir
qui s'asseyait à côté ouais
alors ils ont secret bien particulier
pour faire du chiffre euh bouillon les
bouillons le roulement de la clientèle
le fameux comment on dit en anglais turn
offer
le restaurant compte 326 places assises
et chaque table doit être redressée 3 à
4 fois par soir pour assurer ce débit le
secret c'est de faire manger les clients
le plus rapidement possible exemple avec
ces deux dames à peine installée elles
ont déjà le pain et la carte sur la
table 7 minutes plus tard Laurent est
déjà en train de prendre leur commande
et à peine deux minutes plus tard il est
déjà de retour avec les entrées voilà
comment les clients mangent ton 45
minutes le soir deux fois plus
rapidement que dans un restaurant
classique grâce à cette rotation
Chartier peut ainsi afficher des prix
incroyables comme un neuf maillot à 2
euros et un avocat sauce crevette à 4,10
ticket moyen 20 euros
qu'on a à Paris manger et cassez-vous tu
manges et puis tu te casses mais en même
temps s'ils font pas une rotation de
table il gagne pas leur vie bah ils ont
raison c'est tout l'intérêt
moi j'ai plein de potes qui qui kiffent
même les des trucs voilà chinois les
restaurants chinois comme ça de buffet
tout c'est très bon en plus ils kiffe et
au moins ils mangent à leur faim et
c'est pas c'est pas cher mais c'est vrai
que le bouillon pour moi ça fait partie
pour toi c'est le top c'est le top c'est
le top c'est le top mais après ça dépend
ce que tu recherches si tu cherches une
expérience et je vais voir Daniel
ça on est en train d'arranger le truc
petit à petit là mais si tu cherches une
belle expérience tu vas pas avoir une
belle expérience d'un dîner entre potes
etc parce que tu sens qu'effectivement
un moment faut y aller faut qu'il fasse
tourner les tables mais vu la file
d'attente c'est normal aussi c'est leur
fonctionnement
les équipes de capital ont suivi une
chaîne de restauration rapide qui
cartonne qui coûte un peu cher mais qui
vous allez le voir à ces petites astuces
pour faire croire à ses clients qu'il y
a de la nourriture en quantité regardez
l'astuce frite ça c'est important pour
moi je suis un frite au fil
la meilleure vente c'est le cheeseburger
vendu ici le double du prix de chez McDo
12,25 sans frites ni boisson pour faire
passer la pilule du prix Five Guys a
trouvé une astuce observez bien la
petite portion de frites vendu 4,55 une
mise en scène pour donner aux clients
une impression de générosité avec des
frites qui semblent déborder du petit
cornet l'idée c'est de dire aux clients
voilà on est peut-être un peu plus cher
que les autres mais nous on est généreux
et qu'on en remet par dessus la portion
qui déborde du cornet est en fait
toujours la même
ici c'est un peu plus cher que dans les
autres fast food mais les portions à
l'américaine sont plus généreuses
qu'ailleurs
[Musique]
cette chaîne là c'est lui
qui mangeait ça aux États-Unis et du
coup ça envahit le monde entier voilà et
c'est vrai que c'est cher c'est beaucoup
plus cher
mais tu manges des vrais frites
pour sortir avec 20 balles pour un
burgers
[Rires]
Buffalo Grill ta Courtepaille ta McDo ça
Burger King c'est pas mal mais bon il y
a mieux pour manger du poisson et le
problème c'est que nous à Paris on a une
offre pour manger
écoute moi je vais donner un exemple
concret aujourd'hui
moi j'ai envie de dire aux gens plutôt
que d'aller dépenser au Buffalo Grill un
menu à 25 balles et de prendre avec le
cocktail et le verre de vin et cetera
allez au crayon tu sais pourquoi parce
que au Crillon tu me laisses fines
au crayon il vient de monter une
pâtisserie d'accord avec Mathieu Carlin
qui a un chef pâtissier qui est
exceptionnel là-bas tu as une expérience
assise une expérience avec des
madeleines à 15 euros donc ça veut dire
que tu es assis dans le crayon dans la
pâtisserie tu vas pouvoir manger trois
différents types de madeleines ça a
coûté 15 euros et pas 1 € de plus pour
une expérience qui est extraordinaire tu
vas me dire ouais 15 € c'est de l'argent
ouais mais moi je préfère aller mettre
15 euros pour manger une expérience qui
est extraordinaire plutôt ouais avec des
madeleines mais qui sont des granola
plutôt que d'aller mettre 30 balles pour
aller bouffer une viande qui est pas
terrible avec un gratin dauphinois
dans une zone industrielle que d'aller
dans Paris me prendre une contravention
40 de parking je reviens je suis
malheureux j'ai fait 4 heures de
bouchons moi je suis bien dans ma zone
industrielle avec mon Buffalo avec mes
enfants
[Rires]
et finger là-bas moi perso moi perso moi
personnellement je suis prêt à prendre
il y a combien de temps je les prends
tout les weekends avec mes enfants pour
traverser Paris pour aller tester un
restaurant qui se trouve là là où là et
aller du côté des Grands Boulevards on
est dans le 18e aller dans le 11e ou
même pourquoi pas aller à Montreuil
parce que tu as des restaurants qui sont
bien également en dehors de Paris il y a
pas que Paris et c'est la même chose
pour la province mais il faut aller voir
des vrais restaurateurs et quelqu'un qui
fait pas des vrais frites quelqu'un qui
fait pas sa sauce lui-même c'est pas de
la restauration c'est de l'usinage et
crois-moi qu'au final celui qui est
gagnant c'est pas toi c'est le
restaurateur c'est le restaurateur parce
que le restaurant c'est un moment de
plaisir et je comprends que il y a des
gens qui ont un problème de pouvoir
d'achat nous on y pense on essaie de
recommander tous les jours des
restaurants que ce soit dans mon
émission entre 16h et 18h ou le matin
entre 10h et 11h ça aussi je l'ai passé
voilà écoutez nous on essaie de notre
gueule
on essaie de recommander des restes
comme au cube
les restaurants qui sont pas trop chers
parce que le pouvoir d'achat on en a
conscience mais on peut avoir du bon au
bon prix sincèrement tu ne seras
toujours avoir quand tu vas payer trop
cher pour quelque chose qui est pas bien
alors d'accord alors je vais vous dire
il y a en ce moment il y a une mode
aussi ce sont les 1000 chats
d'accords
sur les réseaux on voit que ça ça
cartonne mais beaucoup parlent de
malbouffe si vous ne rejoignez à 20h14
voilà on parle de de ce qu'il y a dans
vos assiettes et c'est vrai que le
milkshake au bacon sachez qu'il y a
beaucoup de gens qui disent que c'est
pas bon regarde
l'une des spécialités le milk-shake
vendu 7 euros 60 à ce prix là vous
pouvez y ajouter 10 ingrédients à
volonté
[Musique]
c'est l'un d'eux inattendu fait le buzz
sur les réseaux sociaux
dans le milk-shake sur le papier pas
vraiment appétissant mais il représente
tout de même
12,7% des ventes mais 12,7% des ventes
2000 chèques comme ça et tu peux aller
faire mon expérience Madeleine dans un
palace donc après à toi de choisir si tu
as envie de faire une photo sur les
réseaux sociaux et dire
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il va t'inviter il y aura bientôt cette
restaurant
cette viennoiserie très feuilletée avec
de la crème dedans tout le monde est sur
ça à chaque fois tu as des effets de
mode et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
l'influence sur les réseaux sociaux
participent beaucoup à ça mais après ce
qu'il y a vraiment un intérêt à se boire
un milkshake à ce prix là déjà parce que
je trouve que c'est hors de prix 7,50 €
pour un milkshake ils font ils font un
bénéfice de dingue mais qu'il soit au
bacon au chocolat ou ce que tu veux
c'est trop cher ça me dit rien du tout
j'aime bien du cochon au paradis mais
ouais à chaque fois que je peux faire
plaisir
moi je te dis rien si tu veux manger du
cochon tu manges du cochon maintenant
j'ai du ralouf tu manges du ralouf voilà
maintenant voilà c'est toi qui vois et
puis voilà Mokhtar je sais qu'il est fan
de ralouf également il n'hésitera pas à
t'inviter à mon avis connaît bien les
buffet à volonté mais la salle aussi
quand même un petit peu alors
il a également les burgers gourmets qui
cartonnent mais qui sont beaucoup plus
cher que les chaînes de restauration
rapide alors comme on faut-il pour
attirer des clients avec l'inflation
c'est vrai que il y a des burgers qui
sont quand même très bons mais c'est
très bon très cher pour tout le monde
125 euros c'est super cher 12-15 € par
mois regarde regarde
pour faire revenir ses clients par qui
chez McDo Yves doit absolument leur
proposer un burger moins cher pour ce
nouveau burger aujourd'hui on va
travailler un prix qui sera de 5 euros
40 alors selon vous comment divise-t-on
le prix d'un burger par deux c'est très
simple il suffit de diviser le steak par
deux et c'est ce qu'on va faire pour ce
nouveau burger en un coup de spatule le
prix de revient de la viande passe de 80
centimes à 40 centimes et le cheddar
même méthode on casse la tranche en deux
et on va mettre une demi tranche de
cheddar on passe de 20 centimes la
tranche à 10 centimes et le principe est
appliqué à tous les ingrédients du pain
plus petit jusqu'au ketchup coup de
revient 1 euro 11 centimes pour un
burger vendu 5,
alors
après peut-être qu'il met des produits
qui sont quand même valables dedans je
connais pas ce restaurateur donc je peux
pas juger après sur les burgers c'est la
même chose moi je préfère aller une fois
manger chez Hélène Darroze qui vient de
monter
des burgers qui sont à partir de 14,50 €
qu'elle est deux fois chez McDonald's
oui mais oui mais chez McDonald's
de 45 g ou tu as même pas de fibres tu
as même pas de muscles dans la viande tu
as quoi tu as du gras tu as de l'eau moi
j'ai bossé chez McDo j'y ai bossé chez
toi quand j'étais jeune que j'étais
étudiant franchement quand tu soulève le
truc le gris avec de la flotte c'est de
la merde mais c'est bon quand même
comment c'est bon quand même après
chacun son avis Burger King aussi mais
tu sais tu sais pourquoi parce que c'est
bourré de sucre et de sel et aujourd'hui
si je dis le mot Big Mac et que je vous
demande on va faire on peut faire une
expérience à 10 secondes
fermez tous les yeux le public également
ceux qui sont en plateau vous fermez les
yeux et vous pensez juste au bout ça y
est c'est bon c'est pas pour toi là si
vous avez déjà mangé un Big Mac ne
serait-ce qu'une fois dans la vie pensez
au goût que ça pensez à la sauce les
marqueurs ils sont tellement présents
que le goût il vous revient tout de
suite mais après est-ce que c'est du bon
burger bah la réponse est plutôt non
alors que quand Hélène darroz va te
faire un burger bah tu vas voir de la
bonne viande en France bien évidemment
mais tu peux trouver d'autres endroits
je suis désolé à Marseille à Toulouse à
Carcassonne à Orléans à Tours partout tu
as des artisans qui font des burgers de
qualité aujourd'hui il faut savoir que
dans l'offre à emporté aujourd'hui il y
a 40 % des restaurants qui proposent du
burger donc tout le monde a du burger de
qualité puisque c'est l'un des produits
les plus consommés en France donc on
peut trouver du bon burger de qualité
après faut juste être prêt à se dire
voilà est-ce que je suis prêt à me dire
je fais pas de McDo mais je me fais un
burger de qualité
des chefs comme ça vous rendez compte
vous allez pas aller chez alienda Rose
pour manger un truc comme ça vous
mettons vous preniez ça il faut prendre
autre chose donc ça reviendra forcément
plus cher l'addition donc c'est un
mauvais calcul non parce que si les
meilleurs chez Landa rose ce dont je
suis sûr moi personnellement je suis pas
obligé
je suis pas obligé de prendre
une petite portion pomme de terre tu es
partage en deux
partages
mais moi j'entends ce que vous dites
vous revendiquez là la bonne bouffe le
bon burger mais pensez aux bourses par
exemple des jeunes des étudiants comment
ils vont faire pour aller chez Hélène
Darroze payer 15 20 € un burger quand
vous allez oui mais quand vous allez
dans les chaînes de restauration rapide
vous avez un menu à 10 euros même pas
pour des petites bourses qui peuvent le
faire c'est ça qui est démocratique là
vous préconisez de la bouffe qui est
réservé une élite moi c'est ça qui est
bien le point sur lequel vous tentez de
m'attaquer je vais vous dire c'est ça il
faut sortir dans la rue parce que c'est
pas 10 euros le menu pour les jeunes
c'est entre 4,75 € et 5 euros dans les
chaînes pour avoir effectivement un
burger une boisson une frite qui ne sont
pas de qualité moi ce que je pense c'est
que si on parle de restauration faut
plutôt prôner le bon le bon va toujours
être un petit peu plus cher après il y a
mangé cassez-vous vous payez 2,50 € du
burger ou tout est fait raison donc eux
ils sont moins chers qu'une chaîne et ça
démonte encore le truc et ça prouve
qu'on peut faire de la qualité à des
prix qui sont super accessibles tout
comme le font les bouillons les grands
buffets de Narbonne ou comme le fait
monsieur dans son restaurant où il
propose des choses de qualité et même si
on n'est pas à 5 € ou 8 € la solution la
solution c'est peut-être aussi de dire
voilà moi mes lycéens plutôt que de leur
donner de l'argent pour qu'ils mangent
tous les jours dehors et qu'ils ajoutent
des sandwichs qui qui sont faits dans
des galettes avec une sauce fromagère
des frites qui sont pas cuites et trois
ou quatre viandes dessus je vais pas
citer parce que j'ai cité assez de
marque j'ai pas envie de me prendre un
procès à la fin de l'émission non plus
mais mettez-les à la cantine faites le
un sandwich et une fois de temps en
temps qui se paye un produit qui soit
plus de qualité ça évitera des problèmes
de malbouffe des problèmes de santé
également et je pense que ce sera
beaucoup mieux